Speaker 1: Hey, David, 10 percent of the Trump
rioters were military.
Doesn't this make Trump's coup fantasy a real
possibility?
So I think there's a few important things
to talk about here.
One is, remember, any time we're talking about
a percentage, we need to know what the base
rate is.
The research I've done shows that seven percent
of the population is veterans and just under
half a percent of the population is currently
active duty military.
So military is was overrepresented at the
Trump riots, but not dramatically so overrepresented,
but not dramatically so, so active duty and
veterans are seven point four percent of the
population and so far one in 10 defendants
are military.
That means that 10 percent instead of seven
point four percent, that's about a 33 percent
overrepresentation of military in the Trump
riot defenders.
OK, good.
Next question, could 10 percent of the military
imagine that 10 percent of the military supported
a coup for Donald Trump?
It's already the wrong math.
It's already wrong.
About 10 percent of those willing to riot
are members of the military.
That does not mean 10 percent of the military
is willing to riot to try to overthrow Joe
Biden.
So the numbers don't the numbers don't even
make sense.
But more importantly, because of the military
chain of command, even if 10 percent of the
military was willing, able and interested
to participate in some kind of insurrection
to reinstall Donald Trump and remove Joe Biden,
it's just not enough.
It's just not enough.
And it's been made pretty clear, and I know
that there are those who say they're just
pretending it's pretty clear that military
leadership would not support anything like
what Donald Trump claims to be dreaming up
or what what it is claimed Donald Trump is
dreaming up for August or whenever it's supposed
to be.
So I think that there's a concern about, yes,
the overrepresentation of military among the
rioters.
There's a concern about law enforcement involvement
as part of the January six riots.
There are concerns that we could again see
violence in August when, again, Donald Trump
doesn't become president of the United States.
That's all for for sure.
No doubt about it.
Do I think that even if 10 percent of the
military wanted the coup, they could make
it happen?
No, I don't.
And remember, it's not 10 percent of the military
are Trump Kurs.
It's 10 percent of the rioters are current
or former military.
So I don't think that this is actually something
that we have to worry about.
I think we have lots to worry about.
I think there are concerns about will things
get violent?
I think there are concerns about to what degree
will the Republican Party continue to use
the same rhetoric that propped up the January
6th rioters.
All of those are concerns.
What will the most committed Kuhnen Trump
is do when August comes and goes?
And again, Donald Trump is not president of
the United States.
I don't have the answers to that.
But the military is not going to actually
help Donald Trump achieve this.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
You can get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at join Pakman Dotcom
or by becoming a patron at patriation dot
com slash
David Pakman.